foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm a professor in the department of
microbiology and Immunology at the
University of North Carolina at Chapel
Hill
and over the last two years we've been
involved in sequencing genomic variants
of SARS Kobe 2 in the state
uh We've also been sequencing a lot of
other viruses and today I will summarize
the lessons learned from our endeavor
these are some required disclosures I
leave them on for a little while
the research is funded exclusively by
the Centers for Disease Control the
state of North Carolina and the
University of North Carolina cancer
research fund as well as the NIH
we're interested in sequencing viruses
both large and small and that will
summarize work that we have published
over the last two years on SARS cov2 as
well as on a DNA virus called couples
Associated herpes virus
and then new data that we have generated
since the beginning of the pandemic
now the thing about virus sequencing as
opposed to sequencing
human cells for instance that no two
viruses are the same
the example I give here
are severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus SARS cov2 which is an RNA
virus
It's relatively small about 30 000 base
pairs and it's present at a very high
copy number
to 10 to the eight copies of the genome
per ml in the nasopharynx
couple of these sarcoma Associated
herpes virus on the other hand is a DNA
virus and it's a large DNA virus it's
about
five times to six times larger than
sarsko V2 and it's present in relatively
low copy number in Blood and so these
two properties present different
challenges
we didn't come this Auto to this out of
the blue but we've been working on the
diagnosis of fire viral viruses uh since
the lab 2010 2010
we got into a comprehensive analysis of
West Nile virus and the key Insight from
these earlier studies is that we were
able to generate PCR products that tile
the entire viral genome on the panel a
on the left you will see
matched PCR primers that give a product
of the same size around 400 base pairs
and then on the right you will see the
same primers but now combine differently
so that they spend the entire viral
genome
we use the same approach then
for kshv here the problem is that the
virus is much larger
and we still want to be able to put all
the primers in the same tube and so the
design approach is much more complicated
we were relying on a technology called
empty seek that generates overlapping
primers
4K is HV there is a unique central
region that we were able to amplify of
about a hundred thousand base pairs
what I would like to cut
what I would like to consider next
uh four or five important aspects of
sequencing
I will show you that primer directed
amply seek outperforms randomly primed
rna-seq
the viral load determines coverage which
is kind of intuitive since the more
Target you have the higher coverage you
can get
that the amplicon length determines the
sensitivity of the essay
that there is a possible primer virus in
amplification in that some primers will
perform better than others
that there is a possible primer buyers
in the sequence alignment
and so one of the advantages of of the
only seek
enzyme chemistry is that it digests the
primers before Library build otherwise
you would have to use bioinformatics to
remove the primers
and I will tell you what is also
self-evident that there are always gaps
in any approach trying to tile across
the genome and how do we deal with these
gaps
our sequencing pipeline was designed to
generate results within 48 hours
if you push the people and the machines
within 24 hours
the startup is very conventional there
is an inactivating step with tween which
eliminates infectivity
there's a step to digest
nozzle forensical secretions if they're
there like the mucins
that step is not needed for blood
there are commercial ways to isolate
both DNA and RNA that certified for
total nucleic acids the rose per one is
automated and the pipetting is automated
on an open source system
the amplicity technology is commercial
we use two sequencers these are the
high-end or genexes or the ion torrent
S5 and then we use Sanger sequencing to
fill in the gaps
likewise the bioinformatics tools are
pretty much standard
and every complete genome we get is
uploaded to say the international
database that collects sequence
information on all SARS cov2 variants
circulating around the world and they
have requirements in that there should
be less than a thousand undetermined
nucleotides
the first point is that targeted
sequencing delivers even coverage
and we are comparing in panel a regular
hexamer primes RNA sequencing and in
panels b c and d amplicity sequencing on
consecutive dilutions of input you
cannot see two things
one we can dilute the input up to 40
volts and still get the same amount of
coverage
and two comparing A and B the coverage
is dramatically higher
if we use targeted amplification
you can also see comparing A and B that
the coverage is more even and that in
hexamera and polyde heat Prime
sequencing
you have good Peaks at the beginning at
the end and then you have dips in the
middle and also if you look at the Blue
Line the spikes are much higher
so that is the advantage that pump
receipt or targeted sequencing provides
and we're using that now even for RNA
seek of human genes
the ability to call single nucleotide
variants across a wide range of
dilutions is crucial
because we never know
how much virus is in a given sample and
we don't want to bias our analysis
for samples that have had very high
viral load
and so here we have two comparisons one
is the wild type sequence that has
eight variants compared to the wild type
and we can dilute that 16 000 fold and
recover them all
and in the top we're using a mutant
sequence that has 428 artificial
variants and we can dilute that
up to 16 000 fold and still recover most
of the variants
it is important though that viral load
ultimately determines sequence coverage
and the CDC has given a guideline for
SARS Kobe 2 that typically CT values
which is a measure of viral load should
be less than 28.
these two panels are from a report of
2020
you can see here
on the y-axis the log number of mapped
reads and the CT value on the x-axis
there are two primers one is rnas p
which is not viral and you can see there
is no correlation
between mapping to the viral genome and
a cellular primer and on the left and
one you can see a very nice linear
correlation that is as soon as you hit
about 30 for CT
the mapping is linear or correlated with
viral loads so mapping to a genome is a
very expensive way to determine viral
load
on the right you're comparing the number
of mapped reads forces the percent
coverage
and you notice that you need about 10 to
the five mapped reads in case of Cyrus
cov2 to get hundred percent coverage
that is coverage of about 5X
now there are a lot of samples that are
positive and will give some mapping to
the genome
but not complete coverage and that is
still useful here we are looking at
some very weakly positive or negative
samples the white panels on the top show
you samples where fewer than 20 reads
mapped
to the SARS Kobe 2 genome and clearly
these would be random artifacts of
mapping the bottom panel shows you
mappings of 60 to 800 reads
clearly not enough to crawl mutants
clearly not enough to sequence the virus
but demonstratively much better than the
negative samples and so this is an
independent confirmation that even these
weekly positive samples still had virus
in there and had complete virus because
you can see the mapping is random across
the genome positions are on the x-axis
this is from a rather old paper where we
asked a very simple question
does the length of the PCR product
determine the sensitivity of the PCR and
so you can see the CT values on the
vertical axis and the amplicon lengths
on the x-axis
up to about 500 which is in the middle
the CT values are the same independent
of amplicon length and then on the right
as you go from 1042 to
2650 you can see
an almost linear increase in CT values
which is equivalent to a loss of
sensitivity
I also indicated the average primer or
amplicon length of the
PCR collections that's where we are
using that is SARS cov2 is much smaller
than the SARS cov2 Arctic primers or the
case HB primers
this is nothing new it's something that
we're keenly aware of in viral
diagnostic
we know and I just told you that random
sequence Prime gives you nucleotides in
the range of 50 to 800 pieces
Tom please see who's 237 amplicons the
length is 200 nucleotides Arctic which
is another approach for targeted
amplification of sarsko V2 has fewer
amplicons and they're longer and they
perform well to a CT of 30 which is
about 10 000 copies of the target
now below that I have diagnostic PCR
primers that are used by the CDC or the
who
they have sizes ranging from 67 to 113
and they're able to detect targets down
to a thousand copies so going from 200
to 100 gives you a lot more
insensitivity
now for comparison I provide you
the sensitivity of the FDA approved HIV
assays the first one took five years to
develop and went down to 400 copies
the next iteration covers took 10 years
to develop and went down to 40 copies
and now 15 years
after the first essay was approved we're
down to single copy detection for HIV
so the amount of effort that's required
to do single copy detection of viruses
or any Targets is dramatic
and then I also show you in the case of
human papilloma virus the diagnostic
primers that first started out with the
450 base per amplicon
went down to 150 base per amplicon and
the currently most sensitive amplicon is
only 65 base pair and that is because in
the case of HPV we need to be able to
amplify pieces
what we observed in terms of complete
failure that happens really in the PCR
steps so designing the amplicons is more
important than anything
and and really you can use the amplific
amplicons and use them in a Lumina
sequencing and other Technologies that's
not the problem here we are looking at
simple repeats and so on the top left
you can see
if it worked the first time then simply
repeating it will work also
on the next one to the right we can see
that the repeats didn't work so there's
really nothing there
one below in the middle you can see that
we were able to recover something even
though the first try failed and then
that's also shown on the bottom right
there is primer virus in diagnostic PCR
because simply the
primers are designed against the
consensus sequence and if the consensus
sequences
fail changes the primers will fail this
is an example of West Nile virus
where we use the same primer appears
and artificially generated polyun
nucleotides with every possible
mutations and then we ask the question
if we use a reaction where there is a
third primer in the middle which is
called the tacman probe how many will
work and if we only rely on two outer
primers which is the CT cyber probe how
many work and you will see that
there are good targets with no changes
where both are equivalent there are
targets where the probe failed entirely
because the mutations are too big and
there are targets where the sensitivity
drops by 10 CTS which is rather a lot
we also need to be aware that the ends
are always missing whenever we see
through this viral genome because these
are very difficult to Target in
particular you can't make a primer to
capture the five Prime end
because there is no sequence to align to
and then you can't make a primer to
capture the three prime end because
either there is no sequence through a
line two or it is the poly a tail which
has very different properties
than random DNA so in these cases
we have to invest in five Prime and
three prime rays which are very
specialized procedures and they're very
slow in that they require about one
person per week per sample so the result
of that is
a problem in gene bank that most people
who want to report complete genomes will
simply paste the same sequence for the
first 42 and the last 61 amino acids and
repair that from the consensus and of
course
that is not necessarily true
the ends matter equate quite a bit and
so here's an example where we identified
a deletion in the end of sarsko V2
and in case of Cyrus Kobe 2 the enzyme
non-coding and it's the structure of the
RNA that determines function these were
first identified by next-gen sequencing
you can see on the top left a gap
when we artificially generated the
sequence to
include the Gap you can see that now the
reeds are spanning the Gap and you can
see that by Sanger sequencing we've
confirmed this rather
10 or so tiny nucleotide cap
enfold gives us the structure and you
can see that in the wild type in the
Middle top
the yellow sequence is there and when
the gap
is introduced the mutant no longer has
that top left ear
everything else however is is correct so
this is very clearly moving aside for
something and that changes the
replication of the virus
in the old days and with DNA viruses we
had to reside to Maxim Gilbert's
sequencing and in case of K's HV that
was only done once in 1997 ever since
all the ends
are from that 1997 Master sequence
kshv this is now more recent work from
this year actually
has a lot of good DNA and a lot of DNA
that doesn't amplify by pcrs so no
amplicon on the way bottom shows you
regions of the genome that we could not
design primers across
that is not designed primers across that
are uh consistent with the amplification
conditions of all the other 300 primers
we used
in that case
there is only one way you have to design
specialized primers you can notice that
they're all a different size they're
longer they're smaller they have
different efficiency if you compare Lane
number one and two
Lane number three also is smeary so
these are sub-optimal PCR conditions
they all run at a different temperature
and the only way to get these gaps is to
run these individual reactions sometimes
you have to subclone them often we
simply put some or sequencing primers on
the end and then sequence the PCR
products you'll notice their size goes
up to 1.5 and so Sanger sequencing gives
you 800 base pairs and going from both
sides you can then
relatively easily go up to 1.5 by
comparison next-gen sequencing gives you
only
150 to maybe 400 base pairs so the
lengths of the standard sequencing
allows you to spend gaps
this is just a summary slide
showing you different ways of how these
Technologies differ Sanger Illumina ion
torn and nanopore
those parameters change over time as
there's constant Improvement
but what we found and I think what's
important is then that if there is a gap
on one technology iron torrent
that same Gap would occur in another
next-gen sequencing technology and
that's because the next gen polymerase
is designed to work in one fixed
condition for all the amplicons whereas
with Sanger sequencing
we have a variety of tricks that we can
adjust for every single Target
and that is the difficult part now I'm
going to go a little bit more quickly to
make it within 30 minutes
the question then becomes how good is
our our sne calling right and that is
the question that most recently came up
against
when we're trying to deferral find the
origin of SARS cov2 which is done by
looking at comparative genomics
so this is a number of samples from
patients at UNC they're about
um I don't know close to 100 samples on
the top left panel a shows the time
since diagnosis panel B is more
interesting because it Compares in the
magenta
samples that we did generate good
sequence and then the blue samples where
we did not generate sequence and you can
see the shift there that you need a
lower CT to generate good sequence
panel C shows the same again looking at
the magenta versus the blue dots
and we can see the linear increase
the CT is below 28 or even below 20.
and that there are very few failures
there are still some failures and
there's still some successes where we
get the whole genome out of something
that has virtually no nucleic acid and
that's just random variation
and then on the right you see the graph
that you quite often see which is the
percent of genome coverage on the y-axis
as opposed to the full coverage on the
x-axis
and clearly you want to have a hundred
percent coverage at a thousand X
but as you can see there is a spectrum
and that most of the good sequences will
give 100 coverage at 50x
and then it drops off clearly something
that gives one full coverage of only the
half genome is not good enough to
assemble a genome
now I want to look a little closer as
this
abundance in our samples
and here what we're looking is how many
Snips are in each sample so the top
panel a shows that most samples of
sarsko V2 have on the order of 12. Snips
and that's the kind of variation we see
in the population
on the panel B you can see if we look at
all the reads from a given sample most
slips are present at about a hundred
percent so they are fixed in the
population there isn't a lot
of sub dominance nibs in SARS cov2 and
that is a different as compared to HIV
or hepatitis C virus
the Snips are distributed sort of
randomly across the gene in that of 1ab
is the largest Gene
and then they're ordered
um s of course is Spike so that's under
selection and then we can calculate the
distance between any two genome and that
is simply the number of of snips by
which any two genomes different it's a
little bit less than 10.
so if you look at virus sequences
if we want and I'm starting on the
bottom a high confidence snv map we need
two-fold minimum coverage
because even for completely covered
genomes individual Snips because of the
variation might have high confidence and
we can use the confidence of the
neighboring nucleotides to assign
quality scores and so even in a twofold
on average cover genome we are able to
identify some Snips at over 200 fold
quality complete viral genome in my view
is 20x minimum coverage that's the same
as for the human genome and if you
wanted to detect minor variants or
quasi-species you would need an upwards
of 2000 x cover
here's a direct comparison where on the
left we only look at complete genomes
these are present in GIF kiss Aid that's
sort of the virology approach and we can
cluster them
and then we took the same data
and we only clustered them based on high
confidence Snips by Hamming distance and
now we're able to allocate over 67
samples to a tree whereas before it was
48 and that's essentially what we do in
oncology and that we're not interested
in sequencing everyone's genome we want
to know whether there is a Ras mutation
or not and as long as
the sequence coverage across Ross is
very high we can use that information we
don't need anything to the left or to
the right of that Gene
finally the latest data from last week
it shows the evolution of SARS cov2 in
the US or more precisely in North
Carolina and we seem to be having this
Omicron a zoo of subtle lineages
in that the virus is persisting in the
population it's replicating in the
population
it's spinning out variants
but none of them are as dramatically
different from the original Omicron as
Omicron was from Delta
and I think that is the good sign
because he could interpret that that the
virus has sort of found an equilibrium
with the human population
where the transmissibility is high
but there aren't too many surprises in
our future of course that's pure
speculation and that is debated by
others
finally I'd like to acknowledge all the
people who did the lab the work that is
my left on the left my lab on the left
uh in 2020 when we started there was no
vaccination
there were no drugs we just had to mask
and then after everyone became
vaccinated in 2021 and since we've been
able to enjoy each other's company of
course in the lab we still wear our
masks within confined species and ruins
we still wear masks and the wearing of
mass in a diagnostic Labs is actually
very important because the contamination
is both ways it's that we don't want to
get infected by the samples but
conversely
if a person is shedding asymptomatically
we don't want that Viral variant
reported in our clinical samples so
it goes both ways and The Masks protect
both the mirror and the environment and
with that I'm happy to answer any
question thank you very much for your
attention